disney le musée du louvre et le château
de versailles
voici le top 3 des lieux les plus
fréquentés par les touristes en 2010 est
en ile-de-france la tour eiffel arrive
en quatrième position
toutes ces destinations sont en
progression
versailles a ainsi accueilli 15 % de
visiteurs de plus qu'en 2016 avec 7
millions 700 mille visiteurs la grande
couronne parisienne attire de plus en
plus de touristes
c'est d'ailleurs une des ambitions du
comité régional du tourisme développer
l'offre en dehors de la capitale
on sait que paris est une pépite donc
tout cela nous conforte il n'empêche que
c'est un lieu d'entrée pour l'activité
touristique dans notre région de france
et vous avez également dans toute la
région ile-de-france des pépites peu
connu mais connues ou inconnues et il
faut le faire en sorte connaître c'est
une d'un des objectifs du comité
régional du tourisme
la région ile-de-france a défini en
novembre dernier 15 territoires
prioritaires en matière de tourisme
parmi lesquels auvers sur oise avec les
impressionnistes ou moins connus encore
comme hier dans l'essonne avec la villa
du peintre gustave caillebotte récemment
restaurée